Speaker 1: Hey, this is exciting. We have
Speaker 2: possibly possibly
Speaker 1: a new top voicemail
caller. You can call my voicemail
any time to one nine two. David P. is the
No. This guy is straight out of central
casting. You've got to listen to this.
Just no introduction. Just take a listen.
Speaker 4: They go from New York, right? I mean,
unless you do it, mustard, a lot of times I do
listen to you and this cable thing anyway.
I'm just calling you that. You talk a lot of
garbage. You sound like the pressure took a lot of
nonsense things that sound like something to what
you did do not understand. How could you not?
Speaker 1: I'm pretty sure this is real, guys.
Speaker 2: We we looked up
Speaker 1: who this actually is.
This is really a guy from where he sounds like
he's from. It's it appears to be completely real.
Speaker 4: But this guy is the worst
president and vice president we've
got in this country worse than Ronald
Reagan. I mean, excuse me, my language?
What's that guy's name? Jimmy Carter.
Speaker 1: That may have been a Freudian
slip there. Maybe he really does think Reagan
was terrible, but he doesn't want to admit it.
Speaker 4: Excuse me. Why, you know, talk
about this guy that he's a bad president.
He's killing his country, guesses about
people coming over this country legal.
Speaker 1: And these things are always funny
because, you know, when you really break down,
this guy's a character. He's funny.
But when you break this stuff down
Speaker 2: the gas prices,
Speaker 1: they have nothing to do with Joe Biden.
When they were low under Obama, I wasn't praising
Obama when they were high on their Trump and then
low under Trump, I wasn't blaming Trump because
the president has barely anything to do with gas
prices. The border situation has barely changed
since Donald Trump left and Joe Biden took over.
You know, it's it's funny, but this this is
weaponized disinformation and this guy now
who believes all these things that aren't true.
Speaker 4: This is a forget. He's one in this
country. Show back that you know what he was
saying that nobody took a break from all the
Trump, Trump, Trump, Trump. You must be in
love with this guy. Talk about the president,
the vice president, a clown and the Joker,
they know they don't belong to sitting there.
People in the clown, in the inner circle.
Speaker 1: Now, of course, not only have I been
so critical of Joe Biden in some areas
that many of my own viewers say, David,
you got to be. You got to be easier on Biden.
But I praise the guy when he does things right,
like almost single handedly ending the drone war,
as we talked about at the top of the show today.
Speaker 4: This guy is a real clown. Right?
He's worse than Jimmy Carter. We passed a
guy, this guy, and you don't talk bad about
this guy at all. And we do. Junkie? Sure. Not not.
Hopefully, you put this in the air. One of these
Speaker 1: now junkie son junkie
is not a term I use, but again.
Hunter Biden has nothing to do with the Biden
administration, what do people want me to say?
Speaker 4: You know, as I'm listening to them, I
mean, I've got much, you know, presumably every
time I listen to you, I'm telling you, don't sound
nothing like that. I don't know. You sound like
a guy that doesn't know what he's talking about,
Speaker 1: then don't then don't watch, you know,
I mean, people get upset that there's so
many shows out there that I think are trash.
I don't want a single one of them.
Speaker 4: When you got a stupid president, stupid
jokes vice president is a joke. Walked up to
me, I don't know, and then he got the other guy,
the little boy there. I don't know what these
people from. And, you know, and they will say
nothing better, but these people
Speaker 1: whose the love boy,
by the way, anybody know what that's about.
Speaker 4: He was, love them. They are the wish
pleasure, the worst president in this country. And
that can't stand every time I see these two clear
like breakfast TV right in their face. Well, you
know, I don't wish not to that, but everybody's
not every day with this corona virus and he's
got blood and say, Oh, this man really killed
for no reason. And you couldn't get these
guys out here. No, probably not. Instead,
it's easy preferred to do that. They think it's
easy. For no reason. And this is an issue that
actually show that, you know.
Speaker 1: OK, now we're just
it's gotten very, very boring, but that
is a fascinating caller that is straight
out of central casting, of course, not
making a single good political point,
but certainly saying it in a very, very funny
way. We have a great bonus show for you today.
We will talk about the death of Bob Dole, a giant
of the Senate 1996 Republican presidential nominee
against Bill Clinton in the eventual reelection
of Bill Clinton. An interesting guy has passed
away. We will talk about Bob Dole.
Debt collectors can now text, email
and direct message you on social media. Debt
collector a very interesting profession, and I
cringe a little bit at calling it that. A lot
of scams in the world of debt collecting. We
are going to talk about it on today's bonus
show. And also in addition to learning that
Stacey Abrams is going to be running again for
governor in Georgia as a Democrat, of course,
Speaker 2: we are now learning that David
Speaker 1: Perdue, the former Georgia
senator Republican who lost to Jon Ossoff, is
going to be challenging incumbent Republican
Governor Republican Governor Brian Kemp.
That's also very interesting. Kemp, presumably,
would be the last Trump of the two candidates.
We're going to talk about how that race is going
to break down. On today's bonus show, do not
miss today's bonus show. Get instant access
by signing up at Join Pacman dot com. You can
use the coupon code better 21 to save a bundle.
And also remember that our members at Join
PAC Incom get priority access to me during
the upcoming Viewer Town Hall. December 14
6:00 p.m. Eastern on the Pacman Live YouTube
channel. That's it for today's show. See you on
The David Pakman Show. Back with another show.